there's a lot of pressure when you're
making a big important film sequel to a
beloved film how did you guys as the
cast let off pressure how did you let
off steam
well there was there was one night where
we were filming a lot of scenes a lot of
strobe lights and I think we were all
sort of stressed by the end of the shoot
so me and Bill Hader and Isaiah and Andy
machete we went out to the parking lot
we were kicking around a soccer ball and
Bill Hader goes he'll be funny any
machete if you kick the ball at that
office building up their world those
people are working and just immediately
machete kicks the ball machete the
director I just react sure I said he
kicks the ball as hard as he can at this
office window and bill haters like yeah
yeah do it do it do it do it
and I'm like - we're gonna we're gonna
get in trouble like we're in so much
trouble I don't wanna get sued like this
is a lawsuit and so he's just egging him
on I just take the ball and I'm like
this isn't cool guys I just kicked it
onto the roof mad at me they were like
hey and then yeah when the ball would
hit because it was a full building of
all windows and when it ball would hit
it was like that scene in the matrix
really lost his mind because he been
shooting the movie I was building come
to the window be like what's wrong and
then they applauded PJ you weren't
correct